bonjour christiane emmanuel bonjour
monsieur wolton bonjour à tous les
auditeurs
vous êtes la présidente de la commission
culture de l'assemblée de martinique
merci d'être avec nous pour parler de
cette politique culturelle en martinique
mais avant tout nous sommes le 17 avril
qui marque le 10e anniversaire de la
mort d'aimé césaire écrivain poète
politique également la martinique doit
se souvenir des scènes et manuel de thé
l'homme qui a tant compté pour le
rayonnement de notre île il est tout à
fait normal que nous célébrons la
mémoire de ces aires maintenant qu'il
est parti depuis dix ans il est tout à
fait normal que nous soyons en communion
avec lui aujourd'hui et par l'âge je
veux signaler deux manifestations
importantes en partenariat avec la cité
m premièrement le colloque qui a lieu
aujourd'hui autour de la pensée d'aimé
césaire avec des invités de martinique
et de pays étrangers et aussi en
partenariat avec la ville de basse
pointe puisque gradis est un satellite
de la de la cité m
donc avec la ville de basse pointe il ya
un certain nombre de manifestations qui
ont été mises en place mais n'empêche
que il serait souhaitable que je sais
que mes césaire et étudié en première et
en terminale maintenant martinique mais
il serait souhaitable qu'on puisse
amener le poète l'écrivain des labels
primaire je pense pour que ses enfants
puissent apprendre à lire à comprendre
et à aimer le poète qu'il a été qu'ils
deviennent abordables de plus en plus
tout c'est surtout absolument la culture
un martinet christiane emmanuel le monde
riches complètent diversifiant n'en
parle maintenant va commencer par
tropiques atrium la scène nationale qui
va enregistrer le départ de ces deux
responsables y aller hassane kassi
kouyaté son directeur bernard agissons
adjoint deux hommes qu'ils veulent
partir et qui ne veulent même pas
entendre parler d'une reconduction de
contrat vous la présidente du conseil
d'administration de toupie 4e et devant
interpellé par cette situation
alors je je pense que vous avez une très
mauvaise information concernant monsieur
hassane kassi kouyaté hassane kassi
kouyaté yonghua nouvellement un contrat
justement nous venons de renouveler son
contrat pour trois ans mais pour des
raisons familiales
et personnel hassan et se sent obligé de
repartir de quitter la martinique parce
que parce qu'il n'y avait pas peut-être
suffisamment d'énergie positive autour
de non pas du tout monsieur c je suis
vite on sait uniquement et je le
confirme nous en avons longuement parlé
puisque comme nous venions de roux lui
renouveler le contrat chez eux ou trois
ans et nous nous avons essayé d'étudier
la question sous plusieurs formes et
effectivement j'ai compris j'ai fini par
accepter et comprendre son départ de la
martinique maintenant monsieur bernard
lagier je ne suis pas encore au courant
je n'ai pas reçu de mot n'a pas encore
parlé mais nous ferons face de toutes
les façons dont je précise qu'il ya un
nous avons lancé depuis la mi mars un
appel à candidature et nous sommes en
train de recevoir des candidatures pour
le poste de directeur de scène un père
la scène nationale
quelle que soit la personne qui sera là
le successeur devra composer avec une
équation terrible christiane emmanuel
être scène nationale avec un cahier des
charges précis mais aussi composer avec
ce formidable outil de promotion pour
nos artistes que leur présentent atrium
sauf qu'ils ne peuvent pas y avoir accès
comme ça de quatre membres de droit
alors juste pour vous dire effectivement
martinique nous avons une carence de
sale surtout que là nous avions un autre
satellite qui était fonds saint jacques
depuis 2011 fonds saint-jacques devaient
être réparés et quand nous sommes
arrivés en 2016 le gouvernement nous
allions perdre l'apport
de l'état donc nous avions fait
diligence pour pouvoir justement pouvoir
récupérer ces fonds est réparée fonds
saint-jacques donc depuis descendent
novembre décembre 2010 est foncée
jacquet en réparation dont bien entendu
le tropique atrium déborde
c'est à dire que nous travaillons avec
l'autre olympique mais c'est un état de
fait
ouais donc il faut faire avec
l'instrument que nous avons le seul
outil que nous avons nous avions
deuxième outil qui la pagerie mail à
paris ne peut pas être exploité la
hausse il faut faire des réparations
là aussi il faut mettre la pagerie aux
normes mais concernant tropiques atrium
effectivement nous travaillons avec 67
associations
donc effectivement si le seul lieu où
convergent l'armée à quel type d'art le
conte le théâtre la musique
les circassiens trophy katrian c'est
quand même la seule qui a le plus de le
parmi les scènes nationales avoir le
plus de lever de rideau un c'est-à-dire
qui présente le plus insolent je crois
nous n'avons pas encore confirmation
mais je pense que nous sommes classés
premières scènes nationales de deux
français ordinaires alors extraordinaire
mais se pose donc forcément la question
des infrastructures et donc de la
politique culturelle en martinique
pas assez de salles de spectacles de
lieu d'expression de manifestation foot
cela vire 10 serait de toutes les façons
je suis pleinement consciente de ce
problème mais là la politique culturelle
née passionnés pas comment dirais-je
uniquement la sphère de la ctm et celles
afférentes de celle affaire de tous
c'est à dire que c'est un chantier
extrêmement complexe et large donc je
peux partir déjà du fait qu' il faut que
les mairies s'impliquent
alors voilà je vais vous raconter une
anecdote hassane kouyaté vient alors
nous avons un projet culture un
territoire donc nous avions
nous avons acquis comment dirais-je un
chapiteau de 250 places bien équipés et
nous développons un certain nombre de
comment dirais-je de dax culturel avec
certaines communes hassan vient de
rencontrer cinq merde
en bas les prêts à prendre les
spectacles et là maintenant les sept
maires ont décliné l'offre
c'est à dire que nous venons avec
l'artiste nous venons avec tout le
matériel les infrastructures la
logistique les techniciens et le projet
culturel lui même ce dont nous avions
besoin c'est tout simplement des des
agents municipaux pour renforcer
l'équipe de tropiques atrium donc tout
le monde veut tout gratuitement et ce
n'est pas possible il faut que les
collectivités il faut que les mairies
s'impliquent
il faut qu'ils sachent ce qu'ils veulent
maintenant si nous avons aussi deux
collectivités les comment dirais-je cap
man et l'espace sud
là aussi il faut que nous travaillons
avec eux afin de mettre en place des
espaces qui est en friche il faut tout
construire il faut tout construire il
faut tout construire sa part sa part du
de la simple formation en fin de la
formation de l'artiste jusqu'à la
sécurité sociale là aussi nous avons des
problèmes
enfin je dis nous parce que je fais
partie des artistes je suis d'abord
chorégraphe nous avons un gros problème
avec la sécurité sociale nous avons le
l'intermittence du spectacle la sécurité
les comment dirais-je les les
là je perds le pô le politique que nous
voulons pas d'une pathétique vous êtes
peut faire en sorte que ces dossiers se
règlent plus rapidement possible alors
tout simplement forme et si la sécurité
sociale ne peut pas mettre à disposition
une cellule spécialement pour les
artistes
il serait nécessaire qu'ils aillent au
moins en formation parce que nous nous
nous arrive enfin il arrive que certains
artistes reçoivent des déclarations qui
ne sont pas justes où on le réclame de
l'argent enfin bref ça aussi tout est en
friche
tout est en friche no kill tôt il faut
tout faire lancelot si on doit définir
la politique culturelle de l'actuelle
collectivités territoriales de
martinique se serait construire oui il
est condamné à posséder fondement alors
nous continuons un certain nombre de
choses qui t'est que monsieur marie
jeanne avait déjà mis en place depuis sa
première mandature c'est à dire nous
continue à accompagner les boursiers
mettons nous avons des boursiers en
martinique à parallèle 14
nous soutenons cette école parallèle 14
en finançant et en aidant les boursiers
de parler le 14
nous aussi accompagnons les boursiers
dans le domaine artistique dans tous les
pays du monde
report de la martinique nous continuons
à soutenir à soutenir la création et la
diffusion des créateurs martiniquais et
là nous avons avancé d'un pouce je suis
arrivé enfin la commission culture et et
l'exécutif nous sommes arrivés à faire
bouger un peu les choses c'est à dire
qu'avant quand les artistes recevait une
notification concernant leur
accompagnement à une création artistique
le pourcentage était de 60 40 là
maintenant nous sommes remontés à 80,20
et nous avions fait nous avons supprimé
les pourcentages donc ce sont les
petites choses qui vont améliorer au fur
et à mesure le quotidien des artistes
mais nous n'avons pas de baguette
magique pour créer fait inventer des
subventions nous pouvons inventer
réinventer les espaces et la diffusion
en en tunique sachant tout en sachant
qu'il y a en martinique des des espaces
existants comme les vieux cinéma et ça
je pense que les maires pourraient se
mettre à penser à ces espaces publics
utilisent ce genre ce genre oui parce
qu'il faut réparer il faut réparer les
églises mais donc il ya un vrai problème
quant à la culture et même aussi au
niveau des églises qu'il faudrait le
patrimoine je parle du patrimoine
répondez moi très vite parce qu'ils ont
pris par le temps ce fameux festival de
la martinique karine mousseau présidente
du comité martiniquais du tourisme avait
évoqué ce sera elle ne pourra pas le
faire parce qu'il a pas d'argent sur la
culture pourrait prendre le relais
alors il nous sera très difficile cette
année de prendre le relais très vite il
nous sera très difficile de prendre le
relais de cette manifestation mais nous
y pensons pour déjà préparer home et
pouvoir réaliser ce festival en 2019
merci d'arrêter ce matin avec nos
questions d'emmanuel présidente de la
commission culture à l'assemblée de
martinique bonne journée
merci beaucoup